a portion of this video sponsored by
MailChimp MacBooks aren't cheap and if
you bought one or you're planning to you
want it to last a long time and the good
thing is they will if you follow the
tips I'm going to share with you like
this 2012 MacBook gear that is still
running great 10 years later now some of
these tips are simple While others
you've never even thought about that can
make components last at least twice as
long but before that thanks to MailChimp
for sponsoring this portion of this
video MailChimp is the number one email
marketing and automation platform and
they have over 12 million customers
which send more than half a billion
emails each day yes half a billion they
analyze data from billions of their
emails to personalized recommendations
to make it easy for you to improve your
business revenue and engagement I first
heard of MailChimp when I started my
photography business and I wanted to
send emails for my mailing list and
needed a service that works well and
MailChimp not only makes it easy with
Automation and their creative assistant
but will do way more things like help
you build your mailing list one thing
that is super cool is their customer
Journey Builder automations which let
you remind customers about stuff they
left in their online shopping cart with
abandoned cart emails or send
retargeting emails to remind them to
come back for something they saw on your
website so go ahead and check out the
rest of their many features and get
started at mailchimp.com thank you to
MailChimp for sponsoring that part of my
video and now back to my regular content
the first is simple keep your machine
safe you would be surprised by how many
Macs die each year from falling so if
you're taking it with you use a bag or a
sleeve and if it has magsafe make sure
to use that so that if the cable gets
pulled your laptop won't fall down now
you can also get AppleCare plus which
can now be purchased as a subscription
without a time limit so that if it does
get damaged it will get repaired for
much less money now when you're cleaning
your MacBook don't use heavy cleaners or
random wipes instead use a super soft
towel and don't press down hard
especially on the screen now for tougher
spots you can use electronic wipes which
are safe for screens and they won't
damage that really good
anti-reflectivity coating that is on
your screen talking about displays did
you know that they can and do wear out
which is why some older MacBooks have
discoloration or burn-in even with an
LCD display now our 2012 MacBook screen
is excellent and a few ways that you can
get yours to last just as long is to not
keep it at full brightness all the time
and keep the screen on you can also just
lower the brightness and use dark mode
which will help but most importantly you
want to make sure that you're using the
screen saver that is built in and make
sure that your Mac is set to turn the
display off if you haven't used it in a
while which also saves battery which
we'll cover in just a bit now one thing
that damages opponents is extreme cold
or heat so it is best to keep your Mac
indoors and not to leave it out in the
sun or in a car that can get really hot
in the summer or cold in the winter with
that if you're pushing your machine hard
it will heat up especially if you have a
fanless model now they are designed to
Throttle Down to prevent damage but
there are a few things they could do to
help first off if yours has a fan make
sure to periodically blow out the dust
with an Electronics approved cleaning
duster because over time dust can build
up and your Mac will run hotter and the
fans will run louder so you want to make
sure to get that dust out second if
you're pushing your Mac hard and for a
long time like for example when
rendering you want to make sure that you
have it on a desk so those feet can
raise it up a bit and not on a blanket
or something else that will cover up the
airflow and keep the heat in now if you
want to take it a step further you can
use a laptop cooler which we have found
that not only does it keep it cooler but
it also improves performance especially
for fanless Max now when you don't need
maximum performance or you don't want
your Mac to run hot you can also enable
low power mode I made a full video about
this in detail but I've been using this
very often lately and loving it because
with apple silicon MacBooks have really
good performance even in low power mode
it's enough for most common tasks when
you have that enabled your Mac will use
less wattage which keeps it running
cooler and if you have an M2 powered
MacBook they have really powerful
efficiency cores so most of the time it
will use just those in low power mode
and that makes it run super cool and it
saves battery life which is really nice
now one of the first things that can go
bad in a Macbook is the actual battery
so let's talk about how to make it last
a long time now ride of the get-go
optimize battery charging should be
enabled and you want to make sure it's
turned on in the settings now this makes
it so the battery is opt
it will not charge too fast or stay too
high if you're not using it just plug it
in and don't touch it kind of learns
what you want to do now some people like
to keep their Macs plugged in all the
time now a while ago that was bad now it
is not as bad as it was because even
though it could say 100 it doesn't mean
that it is actually stuck there it will
let it lower a little bit charge back up
and it can even just pull power from the
charging adapter which is why I would
say if you care about longevity I would
use a good quality one like the ones
that Apple give you with that you still
want to unplug it occasionally and let
it drain down so the battery doesn't
stay mostly charged for a very long time
have it run down to 20 and then charge
it back up and that will increase
longevity as well now when you are
charging it is better to plug it in and
let it charge up in one session instead
of constantly plugging it into charge
and then you know charging a little bit
and then unplugging it and it drains
down you plug it back in you'll have
better Longevity if it's in one session
now if you're not going to use your
MacBook for a long time it is better to
actually shut it down instead of just
putting it to sleep now Max do a great
job about not wasting too much power but
at some point it's going to go down to
zero and the battery is dead and it's
actually bad to have your battery be
dead for a long time so shut it down if
you're going to be leaving somewhere and
not using it and the same thing goes for
keeping a battery at a hundred percent
for a long time which is why Apple's
optimized charging feature will wait for
it to charge up to 100 until the time
that you usually start to knead it and
at that point you'll just kind of hover
at 80 percent now if you don't let your
battery go below 20 or above 80 percent
in width that you charge in one session
that can double the longevity of your
battery or even more so now
unfortunately apple does not have a
setting in optimized charging to limit
it to 80 but there is some code that you
can use and some third-party
applications that will cap it at 80
percent so if you care about it lasting
a very long time for example 10 years
that will definitely help and if you
want to take it a step further it is
actually better to use a slow charger
than a fast charger now uh Apple devices
and MacBooks will automatically fast
charge up to 50 and then they'll slow
down because fast charging puts out more
heat and then your battery will degrade
faster so that's already good but if you
use a slower charger in general that
will help even more and most of the time
I actually use a 67 watt charger with my
MacBook so if you follow those charging
tips your battery will last a very long
time longer than you need your MacBook
now there are other components that do
wear out and the biggest one is the SSD
now ssds and other dry lives they're not
rated to last forever a lot of the ssds
on the base models they're rated for 150
terabytes written or 300 and that means
that once you write that much data it's
pretty much worn out and it could die on
you now once you upgrade from a 256 Giga
model to a 512 that will actually double
the amount of data that you can write on
there so even if you don't need a 112
gigabyte SSD having double the longevity
of the SSD and the amount of data you
can write will basically double its
lifespan so that is great if you can
afford it I would say to upgrade to that
now along with that RAM does matter if
you don't have enough RAM for example of
an eight gigabyte model what ends up
happening is if you have many
applications open or even a lot of tabs
there'll be extra data that gets written
to the SSD offloaded to maintain your
performance now that is a good thing but
if you have a gigsaw happens way more
often than with a 16 gigabyte model so
if you can afford to upgrade to 16 gigs
that will also drastically reduce the
amount of data that's written to your
SSD and that can also improve your
performance so that also really helps
your long-term longevity so don't skimp
out to buy the base model if you want
your MacBook to last for example 10
years it will be much better if you can
spend a little bit more money and with
that the performance and the capacity is
also increased which will you know
extend the amount of time that your
machine runs at good performance and
that you want to use it so there you
guys go if you have other tips go ahead
and put them down in the comment section
below click that Circle book to
subscribe check out one of those great
videos right over there this is Max and
I'll see you in the next one
foreign